se lo vuoi
rimane
non c'è molto dati e che non si è già
detto
si dice che
domani se solo posto adatto per un bel
ricordo non è da vicino
m non possono non desidera
lasciamo né sistema
sì sì per cena conoscersi
a cascia
non è quello che ci spetta
e bonino
e baci per strada adesso qui nostalgico
presente
[Musica]
forse c'è
domani
e questo è solo un sogno non è stato
male
se lo fa
rimane
e troveremo senso noi che no
che abbiamo più se per cena
forse sì
[Musica]
non è quello che ci spetta
gb
adesso è qui nostalgico presente
no
non desidera
desidera
no
ma shannon e di
ma
[Musica]
prendersi
non è quello
ci aspetta aggiungersi
montale
adesso è qui nostalgico presente
[Musica]
ma se vuoi
rimane grazie
buon pomeriggio e dunque sono una
persona meno adatta proprio
nell'universo cercare di fare un
discorso intelligente su un palco e
quindi per il vostro benessere
continuerò in questa pratica e quindi
canterò per voi insieme al maestro carlo
gaudiello giulia monti e un paio di
canzoni che per me sono molto importanti
e che insomma è adesso un piega lo
grazie grazie grazie
e se vuoi capissi
tutto qua le prime come prima mi
sentisse nuti
io non ho mai
mai pensato
ste
anche un abitudine un bel posto per
ritrovare me
ma senza minore
no io ancora
cosa strana voglia dire
sola senza di noi ma non d'ora
se non altro per vederti andarvi ancora
tema
cercasi
[Musica]
sarebbe per paura e la paura
pure sempre quella vincere
e tu no
[Musica]
macché
niente sia cambiato dopo il cuore che ho
strappato fiat
[Musica]
e ancora
che la strana voglia di sentirmi sola
senza di noi
ma non da ora
se non altro per vederti andarvi ancora
a iunco
per la smania di fuggire via da sola ma
senza dimora
che vola
sul solo aria piume nient altro ancora
certo
il tempo passato insieme a spasso da
questo mondo e un altro per trovare
ogni giorno più stretto per contenere
ogni tutti i denti
un cassetto ed ecco perché a scatto
guardo e scappo
ho solo tanta voglia di sentirmi viva
[Musica]
senza di noi
io
[Musica]
di sentirmi sola senza di noi
onore
se non altro per vedermi andarvi ancora
certo che non apprezzo il tempo resta b
un po addosso
grazie
e per salutarvi e ringraziarvi
vorrei cantare questo brano che io sono
parecchio affezionata e che debuttò in
un certo senso proprio in questo teatro
ormai un sacco di anni fa e sentito la
soddisfa ma il suo
someone
[Musica]
bega e più
io finchè zwei
schumi
quelle
che mai le giunte
mf
[Musica]
exploit
c'è spesso amiche
[Musica]
mai
i soldi
e poi
sì
[Musica]
[Applauso]
cm genere
in china
[Musica]
satisfy my soul
se farla
[Musica]
allora
michael
[Musica]
g
s
chi
[Musica]
icloud
tel
già
qui
[Musica]
il fiore
in vita
[Musica]
adesso
sì
[Musica]
ac
adesso
[Musica]
mais
insomma
palla in mano
adesso
roma
[Musica]
grazie grazie grazie grazie arrivederci